hi i'm chris wilson from grinding gear
games welcome to our live stream and
thanks so much for joining us today
our team had a lot of fun putting
together path of excel's 315 expansion
and we've got a lot to share with you
today's live stream is a busy one
we'll start by revealing the details of
this expansion's new challenge league
then we'll show you how this expansion
is going to dramatically shake up path
of exile's metagame in a big way
thirdly we'll talk about our plans to
make path of exxon more challenging
restoring some of the adrenaline and
terror that you may recall from the good
old days of closed beta
next up we're going to talk about path
of exile royale the 100 player battle
royale mode that we experimented with
back in 2018
we'll be launching a restored and
revamped version of real today
once our question and answer session
with ziggy d has concluded
and this event will run over the weekend
anyway there's a lot to discuss
so let's get started with the trailer
for path of exile's next expansion
many centuries ago our people travel
to this accursed continent we
return to reclaim our
lost relics but rayclast
grips its secrets tightly
we must wrench them from its grasp
[Music]
you no violently we know trade
retrieve our relics and we'll strike a
deal
[Music]
we will follow the path of our forebears
to discover their unknown fate
[Music]
they wait shrouded in darkness
for one who may finally challenge them
wealth and power will be yours
should you survive our expedition
all right i've got a lot to tell you
about let's start with the expedition
league itself
long ago calgary explorers came to
rayclast in the hope of colonizing it
ray klusk did what it does best and they
never returned
in the expedition league you will meet a
group of calgarians who have set out on
an expedition to investigate the fate of
their ancestors
and recover special ruined artifacts
they left behind
the ancient calgarians underestimated
the dangers of rayclust and this new
expedition is no exception
they need your help to protect them from
the undead that rise at their expedition
sites
as you travel through rayclast you'll
encounter the calgarians at sites they
believe their ancestors attempted to
settle in the past
by the time you get there they will have
marked the site with signs indicating
where chests are buried
holes indicating where their ancestors
lie and will have possibly unearthed
some remnants of past calgary and
settlement
due to the unique nature of rayclass the
calgarians have found that the most
effective way to excavate these sites is
with explosives
and that's where you come in you'll
place a chain of explosives across the
expedition
site carefully planning what each blast
is going to unearth
once you push the plunger any undead
freed by the explosions rise from the
ground and the slaughter begins
some of these fallen calgar are more
difficult and rewarding than others
and have been indicated with special
markets
[Music]
once you have defeated the army of
undead you're free to open all of the
chests you're unearthed and claim your
rewards
it's up to you to decide where to place
the chain of explosives to maximize your
gains
do you unearth a lot of monsters do you
unearth more special monsters
or do you go for the chests and try to
avoid combat
[Music]
the ancient kalgooran explorers built
structures on rayclust and you may
encounter remnants of these at
excavation sites
these remnants have various modifiers on
them that when destroyed
apply to monsters and chests unearthed
from that explosion onwards
remnants greatly increase drops but have
some very difficult modifiers like
immune to physical damage you'll need to
be very careful with your decision of
which remnants to chain your explosives
through as they substantially ramp up
the difficulty and rewards of the
encounters
speaking of rewards there's a lot of
cool stuff to find alongside valuable
equipment and currency items are calgary
artifacts and log books which we'll talk
about soon
the calgarian traders have made this
expedition to rayqlast in order to
recover their ruined artifacts
there are many different types of
artifacts and each of the calgarians is
interested in a different set of them
with a unique way they want to trade
them from you for this expansion we
really wanted to play with the idea of
having nbcs that want to trade with you
in different ways
so we have themed their behaviors around
the concepts of gambling bartering
upselling and exchanging
let's meet the calgarians tuyin is a
mercurial trader who maintains a
positive outlook as long as he can but
if you cross a line his temper changes
quickly
huion offers you items with unreasonably
high prices but he's happy to haggle
you can always buy the item at the price
he's offering but if you offer a lower
price he might accept it
counter offer or withdraw the item
entirely if he is offended by your low
ball
he also occasionally sells currency
items so it's worthwhile keeping some of
the artifacts he's looking for on hand
just in case you see an opportunity
rog is an average man pushed into
rayclass's dangers
he's helpful concerned and a bit fearful
he is very happy for you to do the
fighting so that he can stay safe on the
sidelines
he loves making deals and trying to
upsell you
if you buy one of the items that brogg
offers he'll try to offer you a more
complex deal where he improves the item
via crafting
if you accept this deal he'll try to
upsell you again and again
until you eventually walk away with your
purchase if you can't afford one of
these incremental upgrades you can leave
and come back later with enough ruined
artifacts to cover the cost
because you don't get to supply your own
starter item for this process
and have to select an item with promise
from the range that he offers
his incremental crafting upgrades are
priced rather cheaply
gwenin is a cynical gambler who claims
that luck depends on how hard
you believe so you really need to
convince yourself that you're going to
get that headhunter
if you don't it's your fault gwenin
shows you a set of base types with
unknown properties
when you gamble by buying one you'll
receive a random item of that base type
back
it could easily be a random magic item
that you have no use for
but can sometimes be a valuable rare or
unique item
it's probably best to prioritize
gambling on base types that are most
relevant to your character
once you have exhausted all the items
that interest you it's possible to use a
specific new currency item to re-roll
the gamble window to a set of new items
of your current level
sometimes a base type shows up that is a
lot more expensive than it would
otherwise be
and gambling on this item has a higher
expected value than normal
you're taking the risk though that it
could still be junk
dannig warrior skulld is the heart of
the expedition its brave leader and
lawmaster
danic is interested in specific types of
ruined artifacts and wants to trade
these from you for a variety of options
such as currency that lets you reroll
vendor inventories
log books or artifacts that other
calgarian traders are looking
for you can talk to the traders in the
wild
in town or in your hideout they grant
you access to your expedition locker
which is like the heist locker a lock
box for league specific items
which can be accessed in all three
places also we're adding the affinity
system to these lockers
among the many relics of the ancient
calgarians you might find that their
expedition sites are log books
these ancient books chronicle the
locations that their ancestors visited
in their exploration of rayclast
a logbook item can be rolled to have a
set of explicit mods like an end-game
map
each location within the logbook has its
own implicit mods
as well as a theme that controls what
types of remnants can be found there
talk to danic in your hideout and give
him a logbook you have found to go on an
expedition to one of the locations it
describes
these are all exotic places that no
exiles have ever traveled to before
just like how a blighted map was one
giant light encounter with no natural
monsters
the expedition you go on from a log book
is one giant expedition
[Music]
expeditions from log books are not only
different because of their large size
but because there are special objects
that you can interact with using
explosives
for example trees that contain monsters
or items passageways that reveal chests
or bosses and so on
speaking of bosses there are some
formidable ones for you to seek out and
a set of valuable new unique items and
base types that can only come from
expedition content
the calgary people are not from rayklust
so the items do not have the same
defensive properties that ours do
instead of armor evasion and energy
shield they have ward
[Music]
this new base type is a pair of boots
that grants ward and can get mods that
improve it
the way that ward works is that you have
a certain amount of it and that amount
is fully deducted from the first
incoming hits that you receive
your ward is then disabled and takes
five seconds to re-enable at that point
the next hit you receive is
substantially mitigated in the same way
it's quite a different style of
defensive property and works very well
in conjunction with systems like evasion
block or dodge
as the undead enemies you unearth in
expedition encounters are fallen kagura
and explorers
they also have a ward rather than
traditional defenses
this unique helmet allows you to go all
in with ward as a defensive option for
your character
it causes all increases to energy shield
to affect your ward instead
grants you a bunch of ward and helps it
recover faster
this other unique helmet is also on a
new base type that grants ward instead
of other defense types but its
properties don't interact with ward
instead it prevents you from dealing
critical strikes and grants you battle
mage
which adds spell damage equal to the
damage of your main hand weapon
the new base types and uniques i showed
you here are just some of the ones
you'll be able to discover when you play
next week
so that's the expedition league each of
the developers i have spoken to has
liked a different aspect of it
but i have really personally been
enjoying the different trade mechanics
offered by the calgary
nbc's the gamble window takes me back 20
years on a nostalgic trip
and tuins haggling manages to capture
the intense feeling i get when
negotiating
and anyone who really knows me knows how
much i love negotiating
this expansion also promises to
massively shake up the path of exile
metagame
and we're doing that by introducing new
gems lots and lots of new gems
for quite a while now the way we have
approached new skills in path of excel
expansions is to make a bunch of gems
themed around an entirely new build or
dramatically augmenting a few existing
builds
the blood skills and the ultimatum
expansion are a good example of this
while this approach is great in terms of
creating interesting new builds
it doesn't always affect every character
game wide in order to achieve this big
meta game shaker
we've come up with a crazy idea for the
expedition expansion adding a gigantic
pile of new gems at once
spread among as many different play
styles as possible
each of these gems can of course be used
by many different classes
but we use the list of 19 ascendancy
classes for inspiration when planning
these gems our goal here is that
regardless of which build you're playing
there will be new gems that you can add
to your character let's go through the
19 new skill and support gems
[Music]
the earth breaker support gem can be
linked to any slam skill
upon use it summons an ancestor totem
that uses that slam on your behalf
in this example we've created a build
that summons multiple ancestor totems
that each wield tectonics slam
as you can see this build covers a large
area in fiery death while you get to
stay out of harm's way
this is a powerful option for chieftains
in particular due to the various totem
bonuses available on their ascendancy
passive tree
adapt players will also be wondering if
the earthbreaker support allows you to
create leap slamming totems and the
answer is
absolutely
as with other ancestor totems the
earthbreaker support also provides a
buff to you granting some increased area
of effect with melee skills
rage vortex provides a new way to
consume your rage unleashing a whirling
vortex that rapidly hits enemies within
its range
it gains damage and area of effect based
on how much rage was sacrificed
the vortex slows down when enemies
survive being hit by it causing it to
deal intense damage to tough targets
while you can only have one rage vortex
active at a time characters such as
berserkers who are able to generate a
lot of rage quickly
will find it a great way to augment
their damage output
bone shatter strikes your enemies with a
forceful blow if an enemy is stunned by
this attack a powerful shock wave is
released
the area of effect of the shock wave is
determined by the duration of the stun
you inflicted
each time you use bone shatter against
an enemy you take physical damage
yourself
and gain a trauma stack the more stacks
you have the more damage bone shatter
will deal to both you and your enemies
this self-damage mechanic makes the
juggernaut the ideal class for the skill
because they have easy access to lots of
armor to mitigate the downside
also the juggernaut has ascendancy
passives that grant increased stun
duration which help make sure the shock
wave is as large as possible
defiance banner is a new purely
defensive banner skill
while you carry the defiance banner it
increases the armor and evasion of
nearby allies while reducing the
critical strike chance of nearby enemies
it also gains stages while carried near
enemies and can be placed on the ground
to enhance its effects
when the defiance banner is placed it
inflicts a taunt on enemies for a
duration based on the number of stages
the banner had accumulated while it was
carried
enemies affected by this torn also deal
less damage to all targets
the next new skill is shield crush which
swipes your shield towards enemies and
sends out forceful waves of damage based
on the stats of your shield
these waves can shotgun enemies with up
to two hits at once
so while shield crushes great against
groups it's also effective against
single targets and can be used alongside
shield charge and spectral shield throw
we've improved both of these skills so
that the overall aggressive shield build
is more powerful
the new behead support gem can only
support strike skills and is basically
like a mini head
when a supported strike kills a rare
enemy you'll steal one of its modifiers
obviously this gem can't be as crazy as
the full headhunter experience so it
comes with some restrictions
stolen modifiers can persist for 20
seconds and slaying another rare enemy
will replace the modifier you have
active
the behead support gem also grants you
more damage against enemies on low life
in conjunction with the slayer's bane of
legends ascendancy passing this bonus
really embraces the execution theme with
the head support
storm rain is a new bose skill that
fires arrows that stick into the ground
these arrows periodically pulse with
lightning damage that arcs to nearby
arrows
this skill works very well with multiple
projectiles because you can quickly set
up a large patch of lightning death
existing ballista skills and path of
exile pick their own targets like sentry
guns do
they'll start shooting immediately and
will generally target the closest
enemies
while this behavior is usually great
sometimes you want fine controller for
what your ballistas will fire at
the focused ballista support gym causes
your ballistas to pick the same targets
as you
and they will only fire when you fire
your own ranged weapon
it also makes the ballistas fire a lot
faster than they otherwise would
this support gem allows you to
effectively focus fire on specific
enemies such as bosses
explosive concoction is quite a novel
skill it introduces several new concepts
that haven't been explored with skills
before
here you can see the pathfinder throwing
an explosive projectile at monsters
firstly you may notice that the
pathfinder isn't holding any weapons
this is because explosive concoction is
the very first range skill that can
and must be used unarmed it's also the
first skill that directly interacts with
the benefits provided by your flasks
when you throw your explosive concoction
onto a targeted area it deals fire
damage and uses available charges from
your ruby sapphire and topaz flasks
to grant bonuses based on what flask
charges were used
the skill still works even if you don't
have the appropriate flasks or charges
to consume
but correctly managing your flash setup
can greatly enhance the power of this
skill
what we really love about this gem is
that it brings to life the idea of
throwing your flasks at enemies and
having them explode
in conjunction with the flask focused
benefits provided by the pathfinder's
ascendancy passive skills
we're really excited to see what new
playstyles are enabled by this gem
this is the ambush skill it teleports
you up to an enemy
blinds them and exerts your next
one-handed melee attack
this exerted attack has a high critical
strike chance and multiplier
in addition to this helping your
assassinations you can also use ambush
to quickly re-engage targets after
dashing away
voltaxic burst grants a buff that counts
down to zero triggering a burst of
lightning damage around you with a
portion of that damage converted to
chaos damage
enemies slain by your voltaxic bursts
will also explode dealing chaos damage
around them based on their maximum life
you can stack up many voltaxic bursts on
yourself at the same time
consider using duration modifiers to
modify the timing of the explosion
so that you can cast the skill from
safety and then move into a strategic
position before it explodes
when you use blade trap you throw out a
mechanical device with two copies of
your weapon attached
these blades spin rapidly in a circle a
set number of times
dealing damage to anything they pass
through when dual wielding the trap
rotates faster but deals damage based on
both weapons
because it's a trap blade trap behaves a
little differently to other attack
skills by operating independently of
your attack speed
this means you'll have some interesting
itemization choices to make in focusing
more on damage modifiers rather than the
typical focus of maximizing attack speed
summon reaper creates a single powerful
minion that uses fast melee physical
attacks which cause bleeding
while the reaper is active you can use
the skill again to direct the reaper to
a specific location
dealing a powerful attack along its path
the reaper wants to be your only minion
it reduces the life and damage of your
other minions and will consume them to
heal itself and gain damage and speed
buffs
when designing this new skill for the
necromancer we wanted to explore the
idea of having a single ultimate minion
while there were ways to somewhat
achieve this before the reaper is quite
different in its abilities and
interactions with other minions
it also feels much more active and
directly under your control
one quick note though the reaper will
absolutely eat your animated guardian if
you're not careful
forbidden right is a powerful new spell
that fires an exploding chaos projectile
at a targeted area
it also targets the selection of enemies
in an area around the player's location
and fires projectiles at them too but be
careful forbidden right also inflicts
damage on you when cast
if you can find a clever way to mitigate
this harmful downside you'll have
devastating and widespread damage at
your fingertips
the eye of winter is a large projectile
that fires out a barrage of cold
projectiles in the spiral formation as
it travels
when it reaches its maximum distance or
collides with the terrain
it explodes firing out even more
projectiles in the spiral
this type of skill is one we've been
wanting to bring to path of exile for a
long time
and we felt this new collection of
skills was the perfect place to showcase
it
this inquisitor is using the new battle
mage's cry skill which taunts nearby
enemies and exerts your subsequent
attacks
causing them to trigger a linked spell
on your next melee hit
here you can see the player taunting
enemies with battle mage's cry and using
consecrated path to teleport to enemies
the slam is exerted triggering firestorm
to rain down on those enemies
in order to assist with scaling both
attack and spell damage
the buff this warcry provides that your
spell damage apply to your attacks
this property is usually only available
on wands and certain unique items
mana bond is a somewhat unusual gem and
that its source of power relies on your
current mana
upon use it creates a rune that explodes
at a location you're targeting
this explosion can either deal more
damage or cover a larger area depending
on the state of your mana
the more mana that's missing from your
mana pool the more damage mana bond will
deal as it converts a percentage of your
missing mana into
added lightning damage the more fully
your minor pole is the more area the
explosion will cover
this means that being adept at managing
your mana pool becomes highly
advantageous
for example having slightly higher mana
while clearing a map provides greater
clear speed
when fighting tougher enemies having a
lower current runner amount is better
absolution has been designed for
guardians as a spell version of
dominating blow
absolution deals a damaging shock wave
in a targeted area
when it kills an enemy it summons the
sentinel of absolution which also deals
damage by casting absolution itself
the sentinels also periodically cast a
larger version of absolution on the
cooldown
while the sentinel's version of
absolution can't summon even more
minions
they are a powerful army to fight
against
spectral helix throws a spectral copy of
your melee weapon which spirals outwards
from you
dealing damage to any enemies it passes
through
the design of the skill achieves what we
always wanted val's spectral throw to be
we thought it was a really fun idea for
a skill but because of the limitations
caused by the soul gathering
requirements of vowel skills
it wasn't possible to use vile spectral
throw as a primary skill
now that spectral helix can live up to
this purpose we've reworked vel's
spectral throw
which will reveal closer to release one
of the other issues that vilespectral
throw had was that it didn't work very
well in indoors areas
however spectral helix improves upon
this as the projectiles that spiral
outwards can also bounce off of walls
and proceed to hit enemies
rather than simply disappearing upon
collision
over the last few years path of exile
has really suffered from player power
creep
as a consequence of trying to make
compelling content each expansion we
release either gives players more axes
on which to improve their character
more effective skills to use or ways to
craft better and more powerful items
measuring from closed beta to now this
expedition expansion is our 30th path of
exile release
the amount of power creep varies per
release of course with systems like
ascendancy classes providing what like
20 30 40 power creep at once
like with compound interest it would
only take eight percent more player
power per expansion from new items
crafting character systems item
acquisition opportunities
and new skills for player power to grow
tenfold since the game has been out
and tenfold is roughly what we measure
the increase in player power to be
we may nerf the most out of hand cases
every launch but we're only reducing
them back down to close to the new
baseline
the average path of exile character gets
more and more powerful
while we do occasionally add new endgame
challenges that are appropriate for the
current power level of top characters
the rest of the game just becomes
relatively easier and easier
some games handle this by just endlessly
and exponentially scaling monster life
and damage to counteract player power
growth
eventually the numbers get too large and
you need to crunch them all down again
this is a really cheap approach it makes
the game feel like a treadmill but the
developers are just turning a knob as
they hand you new power
keeping you in the same place forever we
don't want to treat path of excel like
that and hence our solutions are more
complicated
at the same time one of the issues is
that players will always pick the most
powerful way of interacting with any
game system
even when that's not actually fun to
play this leads to behaviors like flask
piano or the way that everyone just
picks support gems that basically add
pure damage
as game designers it is our
responsibility to make sure that the
most powerful behaviors are also the
most fun to engage with
with that in mind the balance changes
that we are making in expedition are
far-reaching and are going to affect
almost all characters our goal is not to
just nerf specific builds but to improve
the game
it's challenge and to make sure that
people want to pick fun build choices
[Music]
anyone who played path of exile during
its closed beta nine years ago can
attest to how challenging the campaign
was to play through
early monsters were dangerous and
terrifying able to kill a character and
a few seconds of inattention
players feared going into the ship
graveyard cave because of the flicker
strike ghosts
they were careful around rowers because
a couple of unlucky chargers could
outright
kill them trying to kill a goatman
shaman while he had molten shell up was
a pretty terrible idea
nowadays however the game is a lot
easier we added level 2 and 4 support
gems without increasing the difficulty
of the game to compensate at all
modern league mechanics shower the
player in rare items from early levels
and we didn't make the game any harder
in response in fact
it's very interesting to compare the
difficulty of league content with that
of the base game
for a few years now we've been shipping
difficult leagues where monster life and
damage values are a lot higher than the
regular monsters that players fight
between those league encounters
players enjoy league content because
it's challenging they also told us they
really enjoyed the path of xl2 demo at
exilcon and it was tuned to be almost
punitive in terms of difficulty
one thing we learned from building that
demo was that it's okay for some
monsters to be able to run 20 to 40
faster than the player in part of xl1's
first axe there isn't a single monster
that moves faster than the player's
default movement speed
we are rebalancing the campaign to be
challenging so far we have focused
mostly on act 1 but with each coming
expansion we'll be extending this
further
our plan is that within a year or so
we'll have reviewed or touched every
single monster in the game
while this additional challenge probably
won't stop our most skilled players
easily dominating the campaign or
running through it to get to maps
quickly
it will mean that players who engage
with the content will find a consistent
difficulty level between league content
and regular content
it's worth noting that the behavioral
and balance changes to monsters will
definitely affect their map versions
[Music]
for quite some time path of exile
players and developers have been keen
for a big rework to its flask system
in the endgame flasks grant really
powerful buffs for a number of seconds
after use
and these buffs allow the player to kill
monsters quickly filling the flasks up
so they can be used as soon as they run
out
with five such flasks equipped the
correct behavior was to spam the one to
five keys repeatedly
to keep all the flasks constantly up
without any downsides
this flask piano playstyle was popular
enough that players were improvising
devices to hit all of those keys at once
spamming the same set of keys repeatedly
to get a powerful set of buffs that
rival the power you get from your
entire set of equipped items is not a
fun game mechanic
it's unbalanced and certainly isn't nice
on your wrist
it prevents us from balancing the game
well for players who aren't smashing
their keyboard constantly and seriously
restricts the design space we can use on
flasks
in addition certain unique flasks
completely outclass other ones in terms
of raw damage output
it was pretty clear to us that path of
exile would be a lot better if we did
some serious work on flasks to make sure
that their incentives were aligned with
fun
rather than with spamming blindly most
utility flasks and unique flasks have
been rebalanced
expect a lot less permanent power from
flasks
plus that provide raw defense or raw
power are the ones with the biggest
nerfs
some flasks have been selectively buffed
a bit if they were underpowered or less
popular
in the expedition expansion there are
now three ways that you can use flasks
you can either continue to use the
rebalanced ones the traditional way
or you can apply one of the two new
types of currency items your flasks
the instilling orb and in kindling orb
drop as part of the regular drop pool
from regular monsters and chests
the instilling orb will cause a flask to
be used automatically
upon a specific condition being met for
example when its charges become full or
when you become affected by ignite
this means that in the cases where you
would previously want to time a specific
flask usage
you can now rely on it happening
automatically with the only trade-off
being that it may consume charges that
you otherwise wouldn't intend it to
there are a variety of different
conditions and a random one is enchanted
onto your flask overwriting the others
each time you use an instilling orb on
it
the in kindling orb prevents utility
flasks from gaining charges while active
but provides a big boost to their effect
duration or various ways they interact
with their charges
there are various different types of
boosts so you can use more orbs to
re-roll for the one that you want
when a flask removes a curse it no
longer applies a period of immunity to
curses
flasks that remove ailments now only
provide a period of immunity to the
helmet
if they actually removed it so if you
get ignited
use a dowsing flask to remove the ignite
and to gain immunity for a while
you can't spam the flask before you're
ignited to be permanently immune
if you want permanent mitigation of
elements there are other options for
your build
note that we have rebalanced element
mitigation in general so there aren't a
few options that completely outclass the
rest
monster density and path of exile gets a
lot higher as you play through the game
when we initially balanced flash charge
generation a decade ago
we did not anticipate the levels of
monster density we would reach by 2021.
monsters in acts 6 through 10 now
generate fewer flash charges and
monsters and maps generate
even fewer still so now there's a lot
more strategy involved with flask use
flasks don't gain as many charges so are
a little harder to constantly spam
and aren't designed to provide such a
powerful slew of permanent buffs
but you can control which provide larger
than normal effects and which are
triggered automatically as part of your
build
we have reworked existing flasks such as
basalt and aquamarine flasks and have
introduced new corundum and gold flasks
for a while now we have been concerned
with a power gap between support gems
there are gems that grant huge
multiplicative damage bonuses and there
are gems that do a bunch of stuff you
don't really care about
when you're building a character by far
the correct choice is just to stack on
all the multiplicative damage bonuses
and ignore all the interesting utility
support gems
because their opportunity cost is just
too high
we are reducing the damage bonuses on
the support gems that are clearly just
about huge damage boosts
and trying to give them impactful and
appropriate downsides for example
the control destruction support gem now
penalizes critical strikes
multiplicatively
overall this works out to a total of
somewhere around 20
potentially as high as 40 damage
reduction for a character using a fully
six-length skill
with entirely damaged support gems
there's much less impact for characters
that use utility support gems or those
who didn't have a six-link setup
this achieves two goals for us firstly
the gap between good and bad support
gems has been narrowed creating more
interesting build opportunities
secondly player damage output in the
endgame is reduced which is a goal for
this balance pass
as i mentioned we want to iteratively
restore challenge to path of exile
it's worth clarifying that we haven't
buffed unused utility support gems as
part of this balance pass
it's fully intentional that it's a
reduction of power for the most damaging
ones
when we're designing skills for path of
exile the mana cost of the skill is a
mechanism to allow us to have larger
impactful effects
bigger skills should cost more money to
cast unfortunately this entire mechanism
is currently bypassed by triggering
skills as it skips their mana costs
this basically means that we can't
design really powerful spells
in 315 triggering skills through support
gems will require paying their money
cost
in fact sometimes it now costs more than
casting the gem by hand
thankfully though this isn't very hard
with well-constructed characters
certain support gems that were
originally disabled from supporting
triggered skills like arcane surge can
now be used to support them
builds that use triggered skills are
some of the most interesting characters
in path of excel
and they are often the best
representation of the craziness that our
character customization system allows
we're confident that they are just as
powerful as before but we now have more
interesting design space to explore with
future skills
now let's talk about movement skills as
you know most interaction with monster
behavior is essentially bypassed if
you're using an extremely
effective movement skill this is okay if
you're specialized deeply into
customizing that skill
but is currently the default state for
any character if you use flame dash
smoke mine or dash without any further
investment
these skills have been rebalanced to be
more in line with other movement skills
these are not huge numeric nerfs but do
mean that there is scope for improving
the performance of the skills by
specializing around them
there are many other balance changes in
315 which you can read about in the
balanced manifesto and patch notes next
week to be honest there are a lot of
nerfs here
we completely understand that this level
of change will make some people nervous
but it's time we start actively
combating power creep and fixing game
systems that haven't been working the
way we intended them to
i think that the metagame of expedition
is going to be fascinating
the reduction of overall player power
combined with all of the opportunities
from the new skills and flask system
changes
should create entirely new sets of
builds that we haven't previously seen
you guys are always surprising us with
what you do and we can't wait to see
what you come up with here
so back in early 2018 there was a trend
where every online game was releasing a
battle royale mode and getting a lot of
good press in the process
we had a running joke in the office that
our fast development speed meant that we
could probably add a battle royale mode
to path of exile in one day of
development
as april fool's day approached we tried
to do exactly that
we pulled a few developers together and
asked them to spend no more than one
workday each on their contributions to
this new mode
on april 1st 2018 we launched path of
exile royale
gold buddy
it was a quick and dirty job so he only
left the game mode turned on for a
couple of days
it went pretty well considering it had
no custom balance whatsoever
oh my god i'm getting destroyed
after april 1st we turned the mode off
and forgot all about it
but the community did not forget in fact
they've been quite keen to remember it
constantly and to urge us to bring it
back
but that wouldn't be easy as to actually
make it a decent experience
would require a lot of custom balance
play testing and feature implementation
work
a few months ago we decided to do
exactly that
path of xor real will return today in
fact immediately after the qa section of
this live stream
we're going to run it for the weekend as
a test and then turn it on every weekend
for a while starting the week after
expeditions launch
we'll patch up between weekends with
balanced tweaks and if it's popular over
the long term
new features we have no idea what the
long-term viability of this game mode is
going to be like so we'll run it for
this league and then assess where things
stand
our initial version of real from 2018
used path of exile's default passive
skill tree
which didn't have interesting options
for characters that rarely got to level
10.
it also used all of our skill gems and
unique items as is
where many of the interesting ones were
way too high level for these super low
level characters to ever find
we've made a completely new royal
specific passive skill tree that has
everything you need to quickly adapt
your character for high speed pvp combat
it features approximately 90 new custom
notable passives
a special new left aligned window so you
can stay aware of your surroundings
while allocating skills
and you gain two passive skill points
per level you're also able to allocate
passive skills from any of the three
starting locations
regardless of which character class you
picked
we have created low-level versions of
around 50 iconic skill gems 20 support
gems and over 70 unique items
these royalified items are appropriate
for low-level play and include quite a
few things that are usually only
available at substantially higher
character levels in the core game
the whole island has been improved we've
made the terrain more varied and
interesting
so that the fights feel different
depending on where they take place
you'll encounter flask troves which
provide charges for your flasks
these troves periodically replenish
themselves so expect a lot of combat to
occur around them
there are many other small improvements
you'll notice when you play around such
as an improved spectator mode improved
leaderboard and ability to pillage items
from players through a special interface
rather than having them clutter the
ground
[Music]
you don't need to delete and remake your
character for each game as you could
just reuse your old one which is
automatically reset to level one
your prize for coming first in a royal
event is this new road dinner hideout
decoration
it's a bit like a challenge league totem
as it grows more impressive as you win
more events
royale is available to play today as
soon as our q a session concludes in
about 45 minutes
so patreon path of excel client and when
we're done with the q a log in and click
to join the rail event on the bottom
right of the screen
for more detailed information on how the
mode works check out the news posts we
just made on pathofexile.com
we'll be running the event from today
over the weekend if you don't get a
chance to play royale over the next few
days we'll run it again every weekend
other than expeditions launch weekend
for the next few months
please check it out and let us know your
feedback
keep an eye on our news over the next
week as we reveal the finer details of
what's coming in expedition including
the full patch notes on tuesday us time
we'll move on to the q a shortly to
answer your burning questions but first
let's have a look at the new supporter
packs that are available right now to
celebrate the launch of expedition
and help fund ongoing development of
path of exile path of exo2
and special modes like royale the
soulkeeper and acr supporter packs come
with masses of points to spend in the
store social frames forum titles and
badges
a download of the digital soundtrack and
of course exclusive cosmetic micro
transactions like armor sets and weapon
skins
the soul keeper series comes with an
exclusive pet in that ecs series an
exclusive set of wings on top of the
traditional small and medium-sized
supporter packs that are consistent with
ones we've released in the past
we're also adding an optional new third
tier for each series
this new tier includes an exclusive
apparition portal effect and a slightly
better ratio of points per dollar spent
the introduction of these new packs
should give you more options for what
combination of each pack series you
purchase
like always it's possible to upgrade
between pack tiers within each series
thank you so much for your support
purchases of these supporter packs are
the only thing that funds the ongoing
development of path of excel
as well as expansions like expedition
and path of exo royale
the reveals we showed you today are
already live on youtube view to link to
your friends in case they missed the
live stream
please do so we'd love to have as many
of you as possible joining our
expedition next week
it's time for the q a if you have any
questions from what we've shown you
today
please get them ready because i'm about
to be joined by ziggy d as we answer
your questions on twitch chat
and after that see you in royale